it's every business's worst nightmare
they've been hacked and ransomware is
being demanded and they don't really
know what to do today we have with us
Meg West she is an incident response
consultant and she's going to show us
what she does as part of her role on
X-Force to be able to deal with this
very problem can you help me out what
would I have done yeah absolutely I can
definitely help you out thankfully
that's what I do every day a large
misconception about incident response
Consultants is that we literally only
respond to incidents doing the technical
things but the reality is a large
portion of incident response and what I
do for my daily job is helping my
clients prepare for the incident and as
we've noted down one of the first things
that we do as an incident response
Consulting agency is education for our
clients we go to them and we help them
discern if an incident happens how
should they be reacting to it we offer
things that are called stiffer classes
or that stands for security incident
response first responder classes and we
literally teach these cyber security
people from different organizations how
to respond to an incident that happens
digital forensics how to query logs
anything that can be relevant to
responding to an incident so helping
these people prepare for the incident
and learn how to do these technical
things before it actually happens saves
them from being in a scramble when the
incident does occur well that makes a
lot of sense but there's also education
for the people who are ultimately
responsible for some of these break-ins
employees what do they do on their
education side yeah absolutely so
employee education for people who don't
work in I.T is just as important as
educating your incident response and
cyber security folks and the reason for
that being is that humans employees are
some of the weakest links in an
organization and they're some of the
biggest most widely targeted people in
an organization because they're not
generally formally trained on how to
detect a cyber security incident today
it stands that phishing through email is
one of the largest attack factors that's
how most of the attacks are still
happening people still fall for that
absolutely literally every single day so
what we can do is educate our employees
on how to to look for a cyber security
attack for instance if an employee
receives an email that's urging them to
do something extremely quickly it says
hey Dan you need to click on this link
and update your password in the next two
hours or else you're getting fired the
attackers are trying to play on your
sense of urgency they're creating fear
they want you to think irrationally and
logically to get you to do something
quickly so when we take the time to
educate our employees and let them know
hey you should be expecting to receive
this kind of emails they're better
prepared for it should we have in place
the security tools to help prevent this
yes of course email filters and
firewalls are going to help but there's
still going to be that one percent or
less that make it through unfortunately
and that's why we need to train our
secondary defenses which are the people
and educate them it makes a lot of sense
and I suppose this is part of a larger
strategy education is just the first
Fork of that what is the rest of that
strategy look like a large part of
working in incident response Consulting
especially from the proactive side we
say proactive because it becomes for the
incident is trying to strategize what
are we going to do when the incident
happens we're trying to predict based
upon our industry where our Industries
where organization is located how many
employees we have what kind of data
types we're dealing with we want to
strategize what kind of incidents and
attacks can we expect to happen just
because we're a financial industry
because we're a healthcare industry we
can generally tell based upon the type
of industry and several other factors
what kind of attacks to expect so first
we're current trying to discern that
second we're trying to put in place a
plan we have what's called a cyber
security incident response plan that's
something that every organization should
have it's a plan that literally dictates
what you should be doing when an
incident happens so that you're prepared
and you have a checklist of what to run
through when it happens and that
strategization is going to take away a
lot of the questioning a lot of the gray
area of when an incident happens instead
of trying to discern who do I need to
escalate this incident to who do I need
to call at 2 am in the morning when I
need a firewall change it's already all
strategized out it's pre-planned so that
it takes a lot of the guesswork away one
thing though a part of a strategy to
really make sure it works I suppose is
to simulate and how does that play out
yeah absolutely so how we can try the
strategy into the simulation going back
to the strategy part a little bit one
thing that's really important for a lot
of organizations are to do assessments
right specifically we do a lot of
ransomware Readiness assessments and
what that means is we'll go into an
organization we'll ask them all their
technical their executive experts a lot
of really in-depth detailed questions
and take a look at their environment and
kind of do a gap analysis that says if
you were to get hit by ransomware how
devastating how large of an impact would
it be for your organization and based on
the results of that then we're going to
carry into the simulation aspect of it
once we know your weaknesses where your
organization needs to better bolster
their cyber security we're going to go
ahead and we're going to test those in a
simulation so specific specifically we
offer a cyber range exercise think cyber
warfare or kind of purple teeming going
on where we're going going to go ahead
and virtualize the client's environment
and replicate it and then we're going to
craft a very specific scenario to that
client to their industry and we're going
to put it into play in the actual
virtualized environment and have them go
and respond to the incident meanwhile
Personnel like myself and my colleagues
who have years of training working an
incident response we're taking very
cautious notes we're trying to discern
you know how can we help this
organization do better by watching them
carry out the simulation and then we
write them a report a very detailed
report that says you should do this
better so that you can respond better to
an incident and that really points out
the flaws potentially in that strategy
that you've done in a prior step yeah
absolutely so it all ties in together
very well and that of course brings us
to the last point is is that once you've
gone through all this I'm sure there are
some lessons to be learned that's
something you would talk about before as
a formal practice yeah of course it's a
life cycle I mean no matter what life
cycle you look at whether it's nists the
National Institute of Standards or if
you look at Sans all of the incident
response life cycles go through in a big
circle and coming full circle means
learning from your past incident if
you're having an incident over and over
again and it has the same attack Vector
it's the same kind of incident but
you're not learning from The Incident
That's why it keeps happening because
you're not taking the time to sit down
with the relevant personnel and
stakeholders within your organization to
identify why did this incident happen
and what kind of security controls do I
need to put into place whether they're
technical strategic to prevent another
incident from happening again most
organizations they have an incident they
remediate it meaning they get their
business back to normal operating
standards and they go about their days
they don't talk about why did this
happen how can we prevent this from
happening again what went wrong what did
we do well these are key defining
characteristics that we need to identify
during incidents to help prevent them
from reoccurring yeah because being a
victim is very expensive well that is
excellent advice I want to give you the
last word on this for our people who are
watching this and want to avoid being a
victim what do you really recommend they
do now yeah that's a great question I
recommend not waiting for the incident
to happen I recommend getting an
incident response retainer acquiring
them ahead of time to prepare for an
incident because the reality is all
these organizations they think oh I
don't want to spend you know a couple
thousand oh let's be realistic it's a
lot more than a couple thousand but they
think I don't want to spend the money
ahead of time for an incident that may
never happen the reality is as the
saying goes the incidents already
happened to you or you don't know it's
happened yet we as cyber security
incident response professionals
literally see day in and day out these
same incidents that are occurring
different environments whether it's
Linux or Windows but we are trained
professionals who are there to handle
your organization's worst day while your
executives are running around like
chickens with their heads cut off we're
there to be calm to help you walk
through it to help remediate it and
recover from it as quickly and
effectively as possible so prepare for
the incident before it happens take the
time to do it put a process into place
and hire an instant response retainer
it'll make your life so much easier I so
much appreciate the part about being
calm yeah calm down this is one of the
key defining factors for being an
incident response consultant while
everyone else is just running around
frantic you know sending angry emails
scared out of their minds having that
person to be your Pillar of Strength to
turn to has done this day in and day out
for many years of their life it's it's
something that money is you know no
trivia for well thank you so much for
joining us Meg and for those who are
watching hey before you leave don't
forget to hit like And subscribe